pull out your mobile phone for a second
yeah let's go that it's put on the desk
and I just want you to look at it for me
okay now human beings very inventive
creatures okay
many creatures invent things but we're
we're like invention is our thing right
so we invent objects with the intent to
generally solve a problem what problem
does this is this design us all people
say convenience convenience in what way
like what kind of convenience is this
soul emojis we invented this rule I'm
going to come back to that in a second
we invented phones because we wanted to
talk to people and we're to draw people
from a distance right then we invented
smart phones because we were like oh we
want to be able to access the internet
as well this can get into network then
been great now here's the thing emojis
was it was a joke but actually is not
really we invent a thing with a purpose
but when then we discover actually this
thing is far more powerful than we
originally intended and it can do lots
of things that we didn't originally
expect like trivially emojis or more
seriously things like does anyone know
what the Arab Spring is does anyone
heard of that before
the Arab there's an S there I'll use
that the Arab Spring this was um this is
about oh how many years ago was it now
maybe six to seven years ago I think
where many Arab nations sort of went
into chaos because suddenly there are
all these popular uprisings right people
were wanting to try to overthrow
dictatorships in a like kind of theme
and they came in a real way from these
because suddenly people could
communicate to each other in a secure
way that the government could not
control right so we invent things and we
have an intent for them like find an
area right a simple problem and then we
discover they can do things these these
inventions we have they can do things
that we didn't necessarily expect so
underneath this I want to making a
little subheading which is an unexpected
side effect
okay now what I'm gonna get us to think
about is look what's happened to my
there we go
this function here
okay now what we're gonna do here is
we're going to think about this this
problem of using integration and just
see what happens out of just an invented
problem okay so for instance if this is
f of X 2x minus 4
then what happens if we consider I've
got two numbers here yeah
from 0 to 4 what will happen okay we can
treat this as an area or we can treat it
as a primitive for now just trust me for
a minute I'm going to treat it as a
primitive just to help us get a bit of
practice with this Oh
oh yeah okay now if I'm treating it as a
primitive I'm going from zero to four of
2x minus 4 DX right so now I can work
out the period this quite easily
contacts all my big square bracket to
indicate I'm about to write the
Promethean here what's the derivative of
2x x squared very good the premium of
minus 4 is minus 4x fantastic primitive
is over and then I say I'm going to
evaluate from 0 to 4 okay now on the
next line what I'm gonna do is this is
my I'm just just someone realized
something I'm gonna write just over here
what the next line will look like it's f
of a take away f of a right and it's
really important to me that what we do
is we actually write this step as a
straight substitution you can probably
work out the numbers quite easily but
I'm deliberately not doing it until the
next line so I can see the thought
process or rather so I can show you the
foot process so you can show the marker
you get the idea so let's do it f of B
that's 16 that's 4 squared isn't it take
away 16 that's that's f of bit happy
where B happens to be 4 okay then I'm
going to take away f of a which is 0
takeaways you
before I just write down the next line
which is pretty trivial I want to point
out because I love you who are you at
this hour but we didn't discuss it all
together why did I write the primitive
without a + C because that's what we
cook we sort of made a big deal about
that like make sure you don't forget the
constant ok why did I not include it and
the reason why is suppose I did write
watch what happens when I do this line
watch what happens if the plus C is in
the primitive then it should be in here
and in here do you agree but then look
what happens as soon as I actually do
this whatever the plus C was it just
gets subtracted from itself so it
doesn't matter it might as well have
never been there
does that make sense so therefore that's
why I don't need to write it okay so
tell me what the answer is now I don't
know about you but most areas that I
calculate a non zero in fact of the
area's I calculate I'm never zero so
what's going on well we need a bit of a
picture so I'm going to ask you to help
me draw this from here here what does it
look like okay well I'm pretty sure this
is what it looks like
okay 2x minus four I can see there's a
um a y-intercept down here when I go
across two years I've gone up four so
that corner there is two and then once I
go across another four units I come all
the way up to that should be positive
four okay now if I go back to my
definition that I've hopefully written
here I'll change them all back to X's
because I'm thinking that X is right now
f of X DX is supposed to be the area
bounded by the curve the x-axis look at
where the x axis is x equals a which in
this case is x equals zero this guy here
and x equals 4 which is this dotted line
just on the edge okay now zero this is
the area that is defined by this
integral so how on earth did it come up
with zero because it doesn't look like
zero to me there so what was the problem
we designed this tool to solve again
what we trying to solve we're trying to
find like an area right one of things we
know that areas that they're positive
it's a measured thing okay but all of a
sudden we have created a tool that has
more powers than we intended it for to
have because this tool this tool can
distinguish between areas that are
negative and areas that are positive now
because you can see this and this is why
it's very deliberately designed okay
these two areas here are exactly equal
right so they exactly cancel each other
out so therefore that's why well the
positive and the negatives eliminate
each other so you know is zero okay now
that's a bit weird that's a little bit
weird okay let me point out if you were
asked the question
tell me what's that green area if you
said zero you would be wrong because
that's clearly not a zero area this is
two triangles and they're putting
together and you two but that'll be
eight square units okay so if I asked
you just what's that area it's eight
square units
but if I asked you what this integral is
you would have to say it's zero now this
is a bit weird this is where it gets a
bit murky because I said these integrals
are areas well they're a little bit
different because now in this world of
Cartesian coordinates that kind of thing
I can have negative areas it doesn't
make sense in our previous schemes you
can't have a negative area or or a
negative length but you can here okay
now let me try and make sense of why
this has to be it's not just some weird
oddity okay what was the metaphor we
started with today we started with the
rocket traveling right it traveled 60
kilometers per hour then it traveled
hundreds Ferry etc look at this graph if
this is the graph of velocity compared
to time for astronaut what is the
astronaut doing now they're not going 60
kilometers per hour and then change it
to 100 they don't seem very very
different okay let me ask you this for
example this point right here at x
equals two tell me what the astronaut is
doing this is a graph of f dash right
this is a graph of their velocity what
is the astronaut doing right there
Michael the astronaut is turnaround
because look right there exactly zero
there the velocity is your so this
staying still for a split second but
before that see down here the velocity
is a negative number so they're
traveling backwards and then over here
they're traveling forwards so in between
there they had to turn right
that's a turning point okay now to help
you visualize what's going on we know
what the primitive is don't we
let's just let's just graph the previous
that's actually where we started this
morning with the astronaut right help me
this is what it's going to look like x
squared minus 4x right what's it look
like what kind of shape is it it's a
parabola right what can you tell me
about this parabola it's a its
x-intercepts are 0 and 4 so 0 + 4 0 + 4
4 that's not a coincidence is it is it
concave up or down up
so this is my displacement graph this is
the position can you tell me why the
answer has to be zero what was the
original the very first question I asked
you how far have they traveled right how
far they traveled well how far are they
they started here right at the starting
point then they went down then they came
back up we'll buy time for where are
they and the answer is they are back
where they started does that make sense
and geometrically this is the reason why
I see that plus C doesn't matter
supposin was plus 6 I don't know what
would the graph look like
it would look something like this right
it's moved up but look you start at 6
well you end at 6 as well you're still
total displacement is still 0 does that
make sense so sorry scales a bit off
this is a really important idea and it's
kind of confusing to be frank ok
especially at this beginning point
integrals introduced us to this idea
that areas can be negative based on the
fact that their position tells us
something if they're below the axis
right if I ask you to do the integral
from 0 to 2 let's let's just quickly do
it here if I went from 0 to 2 of this
guy right what what happens from x
squared minus 4x from 0 to 2 tell me
what happens to the upper boundary this
2 when I put it in it's going to be 4
minus 8 do you agree I'm gonna put it in
take away 0 is that okay
negative 4 of course it's negative 4
because it's just this triangle right
the entirety of its areas below the
x-axis so it's negative